the sportiest version of Audi's second
largest SUV has an S in front of its Q
one of the many differences between the
sq5 and the q5 is that the suspension is
thirty millimeters lower car tester
Matas Cora knows how agile the sq5 is in
curves
it also has variable shock absorber
control so you can choose between
comfort and Road feel for a bit more
money you can get pneumatic suspension
which will allow you to raise the car to
drive on dirt or lower it for pavement
image of the starter order of violence a
big defender contributing to the dynamic
driving behavior the sporty Quattro
all-wheel drive has software to brake
the wheels and the inside of a curve
what matters really likes is the
steering depending on your speed and
angle of steering it noticeably supports
the transmission ratio and the power
steering this may not be a go-cart but
the steering is very direct and precise
of course if you have passengers who
aren't used to a car that responds so
quickly maybe you should steer a bit
more smoothly of delay Vigo and as far
as their gear thomas mcdonell shaman and
the scene for estiga the swollen potato
the Khan responds well even though it
weighs almost two tons
limbed in denominations for mothers
dynamic driving characteristics aren't
everything in the sq5 appearance plays
an important role to the normal q5
already has very striking lines but many
details have been sharpened even further
in the S version 20-inch wheels are
standard our test car even has 21 inch
wheel rims the optional pneumatic
suspension lets you take the car off
road mater says the designers have
achieved a sporting appearance worthy of
the vehicles dynamic character he does
quibble about one detail that doesn't
support that impression from a distance
you might think that this is the exhaust
but it's just a panel the real exhaust
pipes are under the car until emphatic
will a look under the hood at the engine
compensate for that mutter says this is
the real core of the car the 260
kilowatt 3 litre v6 TFSI engine he
removes the cover which is still a bit
hot take a look at this heat shield
under it is the turbocharger which
brings the exhaust together just before
the turbine that means maximum torque is
already reached at just 1500 rpm and
stays there up to 4,500 rpm that's what
makes this car accelerate so powerfully
we get diesels out to our soup Arianna
fauna
it's Sprint's from zero to 100 in five
point four seconds top speed is 250
kilometers an hour average fuel
consumption is rated at 8.5 liters per
100 kilometers
[Music]
the Montes notes that the interior of
the sq5 is fancier than that of the q5
contrast seams on the steering wheel are
standard these honeycomb upholstered
seats cost a bit extra but the standard
seats with Alcantara leather are very
attractive but I can't Agha an entire
about you can even order seats that have
an optional massage function they make
the sq5 not only a top-notch sports SUV
but also a very comfortable long
distance travelling car
[Music]
Madame compress whenever Montes points
out that the sq5 starts out at about 65
thousand euros in Germany that's
expensive but it has a lot more
equipment design and driving fund than
the normal q5
[Applause]